hey guys i'm ryan right i'm jerry jerry
and or we met in first grade became best
friends in third grade because of a
little something called Pokemon Pokemon
gotta catch em mom man there was a time
in my life whoa no no no was it time in
my never mind Oh No hey can I get in on
the action I'm rock how we talk I also
like how you're mr. Batian and movement
looked like you're well it's animated
we're doing something that's weird it's
brad anime hey we're gonna watch 10
things you didn't know about pokemon
sorry kids dead things you didn't know
about pokemon from the channel
alltime10s here we go
pokemon cards become so valuable that
time place forgot the Mafia problem what
the rarest trading contacts sold for
over two hours
pokemon money
no way
the dollar coin
though saying it and no harm very few
Vatican
you must know the camper
Liddy everything
Gillian
800 million
it's pretty cool back
almost failed eyes don't do technology
to slide me and now watching videos
lattice content actually go fast
ah that would not have been a school
oh yeah they get you rock appealing
deploys the answer
Raja
ah after realizing going cared rock
Oh
because army impellers to delve a
seizure going
yes
I
wow I forgot how impactful Pokemon was
man oh dude like that is crazy why did
it say that the Italian police were
worried about the Mafia profiting from
counterfeits they said like some of the
cards had reached like mega value like
this then they say like something sold
for like $20,000 like yeah we gotta sell
these Pokemon gods you dumb son of a
[ __ ] yo you see this holographic charge
all right here is what 50 G's get your
ass to the trading gunshot I'm gonna
give you my Blastoise I'm gonna give you
my Blastoise get out whatever God you
want but you ain't taking my blast oi
please always do robbery you know to
here a play pokemon on the rarest
trading card sulfur 20 grand that is
awesome i wonder what card that was but
i like Charizard masturbating no no no
no it's actually just one of those green
health care remember when they released
the ancient Mew yeah at the movie
theaters and everyone who paid like 600
a member we knew a girl LC Larson kunkel
zoom just bought like that car for [ __ ]
ton of money then I was like cool I'm
gonna go watch pokemon 2000 no it's
talking about the first movie no the
second one what I got one though and I
only ever saw the frisbee yeah they
released it on the second one the one
we're Tracy oh I remember the idea of
Tracy anyway I never said I saw a
comeback kids do it it's weird I hadn't
thought about that like that they
thought Brock would be racist here or
procedures races even they're like yeah
Japanese animation that was kind of
racist though yeah I don't know how to
process bronco ii struck me as kind of a
lonely dude his lone one it was warning
first yeah raag wants to mate with every
yeah he's like a cat who hasn't been
neutered yes see when I saw that fat
come up I was like I thought they were
gonna say that they took him out of the
American show for a little while because
they thought he was gonna teach kids to
be like womanizers yeah
why I don't think I don't even think of
his eyes like the obvious one was like
Christians condemning Pokemon sorry to
say it but it's like it's a while what
are what a Christian groups not
condemning these days oh yeah that's the
one where you go like this sounds silly
but you know I believe it happened yeah
exactly the Creator bases love of
Pokemon off of his love for collecting
insects I wonder if he made them fight
too yeah that'd be cool if you made them
fight if you mean like a cockroach go up
against one ant ain't met answer strong
now as we've recently come to know oh
but they have to work together though
yeah in order for them a really
possessed stirring to be truly effective
me I don't seems really mean yeah you
get like a tarantula vs. a centipede
like me Yeah right out of you [ __ ]
scary I hate tarantulas yeah well on
centipedes are freaky too oh it's ranch
Allah versus the human centipede what if
the creator made that I mean they would
probably just be kind of bothersome for
the human centipede unless it was like
really big branch dared they should make
an enemy of the human centipede they
would go way more worse but he almost
failed high school and didn't attend
college hey man yeah desperate it's
about me it's like that's me I want it's
cool like you know get some burgers I
have laziness I mean you know what
Sachin see you know it's a well-worn
message but it's like even even a dude
you know you know when Asperger's who
you know didn't even finish high school
like are almost didn't finish high
school created this thing that we all
know and many of us it's pretty
inspiring there it shows you that you
can be successful without a college
degree you're all about it good luck
being broke um they said the original
Pokemon he was gonna start with was
clefairy yeah which is I just want to
know why I just wouldn't have been down
for that i'm pretty sure i would have
turned off the show immediately there is
something about you know sort of pop
culture sociology or it's like if you
had swapped out picture for cliff right
i can kind of see like how it makes
sense that people are aesthetically
driven like that so maybe people just
wouldn't have watch but Pikachu's so
kind of iconic and cute that like like
they said it's like we want something to
appeal to both boys and girls it's like
this if there's one Pokemon people know
it's Pikachu yeah it's like that that
choice
could have been all the difference
between this giant Empire and something
that was short lived because this Ashes
number one buddy it's an aesthetic thing
it's just what clefairy kind of looks
like it's like I it seems like more
people would universally be like Pikachu
so cute oh my god i want one where it's
like cliff areas like what is that got
him Elvis hair doing weird vent ears
this gross click very look so sweet you
did it looks like a [ __ ] like tumor
doesn't look like a [ __ ] tumor this
looks like someone's genitals like
that's what their Tesla's read about
this it looks like what their testicles
turn into like that's their penis right
there the penis is the curl at the top
my hair that is not hair I don't care
what anyone says [ __ ] is that supposed
to be here it's just skin dad maybe it's
like that maybe it's like a little skin
flap thing maybe it's almost like a
trunk that over years of evolution just
became unnecessary what was the thing
about seizures well any episodes cause
seizures and then the military decided
to use that as inspiration I guess to
create a seizure gun you hear that the
military's watching pokemon accidents
that happen to the public are the best
way sometimes to learn about what
weapons maybe it was an experiment from
the government that's a creepy wow
that's a very creepy conspiracy theory
because you want to be like hey we just
want to slip this effect into your shows
to see what will happen to people and
then you know that's all the data they
need a lot of the millions of people is
700 maybe they only a broadcast that
particular feed to a choice amount of
people hmm maybe they only broadcast
that version with I guess there's
probably like Astro of effect or
something the electricity maybe they
only pumped that into like a thousand
homes and out of a thousand people 700
dead season pretty effect oh my god yeah
it's not a lot about [ __ ] just now
anyway guys if you needed the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
true thanks oh you can check out reasons
to Jerry on this channel good stuff and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
Twitter
in periscope and we're gonna be going to
VidCon this week so if we're a little
bit lay on uploading videos that is why
Anthony penny look I have nothing
against gay people this is anthony penny
that sounds like a pretty gaming you
know it's not a good way to start a
sentence you know something little
anthony penny come on what Anthony PADI
paper it's not like Anthony today I mean
like it sounds like a game person like
named himself oh you said hi I've been a
fan of your child for a long time and I
think you are hilarious hopefully you
still think that again I please have a
shout out thanks Ryan well dude Anthony
fanny um I think we kind of gave you
your shout out already yeah I did we
didn't even know we didn't even know we
were doing it hi Anthony pay I just had
to say hi compare you in the magic is it
no it's not dude is a name for I'm not
gay but for my mistaken all gay people
can do magic right uh we have to go to
school to learn it I don't know if
you're any more likely to be magically
inclined if you're homosexual you're a
homosexual Harriet a submission instead
of wizards it was just about gay people
things like the metaphor would stop
being coded just after he gets to a year
in Hogwarts it's just like that it's
just him living his life subs becoming
like a message about anything Harry
finds out he's gay he goes and has a
bunch of gay friends then you know
people try to destroy their gay
lifestyle but that harry potter [ __ ]
anthony penny no it's not i wasn't in my
version but yeah we will be show up you
won't I don't know these are the zoo do
a terrible S&M scenario by my ass hurry